uh one other quick clip i got to play
for you
alec baldwin
is uh still i guess defending himself i
don't know what you call this but here
he is ranting in his car i don't know
what this guy thinks he's doing ranting
in his car what kind of weirdo does that
um about the the shooting listen
the best way
the only way
we can
honor
the death of helena hutchins is to find
out the truth
that's what i'm working toward insisting
on demanding
that the
organizations involved in this
investigation
uh do everything in their power
everything in their power to find out
what really happened that's all that
matters
the best way to honor
the death of helena hutchins is to find
out the truth
and um
any suggestion that we're not complying
myself and any lawyers i'm working with
or whatever is a lie that's a lie we're
gonna as soon as we go through this
process then by all means we will comply
but um
but
i have no worries about that i have no
worries about that that's all gonna work
itself out regardless of what they say
in these
right wing rack sheets and
people who are all about hate
um but setting aside all the
hate
setting aside all the january 6th of it
all
there it is
what
why did he hold up a packet of splenda
what
i never actually watched this clip so
i'm i'm uh
befuddled
so he held up a packet of splenda in
which he had drawn a smiley face
and
like oh okay uh well
i guess he's innocent your honor
this i if he ever ends up in court i
guess this is what he could present
your honor your honor i present exhibit
a
splenda i rest my case
well but that would require him to go to
court and be charged with the crime
which he has not been
instead he's making videos in his car
saying we have to figure out what
happened
we got to get to the bottom of this
i mean the hubris on this guy the
gumption
he he pointed a gun at someone and shot
them
and is now saying oh what have we need
to figure out what happened i am
dedicated to getting to the bottom of
this uh you well you picked up a gun
pointed at someone who shot him in the
face like that's what that's what
happened
i'm pretty sure that's it
it's actually not very complicated
but compare this here's the only point i
really wanted to make about this
um
alec baldwin accidentally shot and
killed someone
assuming that was accidental which i'm
you know we can't even be sure of that
but let's just assume that it was
so he pointed a gun at someone and shot
them
has not been charged with any crime at
all
kim potter
uh
accidentally
shot a dangerous violent criminal in the
course of trying to make an arrest
and she's going to prison
so
what is that is that male is this an
example finally of male privilege well
no it's not male privilege
this is leftist privilege this is uh
being a rich famous celebrity privilege
and those are you want to know what
privilege looks like like those are two
forms of actual privilege there's
ideological privilege
and then yeah there's the good
old-fashioned i'm rich and famous
privilege
that is real privilege and that is
enduring
we've always had that kind of privilege
in america it's that's always existed
and it will probably always exist um
into the future
that this dude is in his car waving
around packets of splenda a free man
while kim potter's potter is going to
prison for who knows how many years
for what we know is an actual accidental
shooting where she didn't shoot some
some poor innocent woman who's a
cinematographer in hollywood
she shot a violent danger scumbag
whose death
is
is
in many ways a benefit to his community
his community's better off without him
because he's a terrible awful violent
horrible horrifically evil person
she goes to prison not him well i hope
you enjoyed that clip from the matt well
show if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button right down there so you
can stay up to date on all of our future
content